Welcome friends. Whether you're out on a
walk,
running errands, or relaxing at home,
it's wonderful to connect with you.
Today we are going to be talking with
Annette Mullen.
Annette is a retired Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department leader
with 24 years of experience. Now Annette
spent over two decades investigating.
Violent crimes and nine years as a crisis
negotiator,
eventually leading the crisis negotiation
team.
Today, as a negotiation instructor and
coach at the Black Swan Group,
Annette translates those high-stakes
experiences into practical tools for
leaders,
teams, and individuals navigating
pressure,
conflict, and growth.
Annette, welcome to Phoenix and Flame.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm really looking forward to this
conversation with you,
Dana.
This is going to be so interesting.
Now I have to throw the in here.
I did some research on LinkedIn and guys,
you're gonna be fascinated with this.
Now, Annette, you have a master's degree
not only in theoretical
and mathematical physics. Did I look at
that correctly?
And I have a master's degree in theology.
Theology, Christian leadership.
That sounds oo
correct. Way too smart for me to be
theoretical mathematics.
I can barely count on my fingers.
'Cause I thought that was gonna be
such an interesting I thought,
my gosh, I've got to br I said,
How does how does somebody's brain do
that?
My brain for sure
does not. When you talk about boundaries,
there's one right there.
I love it. So your master's is in
Christian leadership.
Got you.
Correct. Correct.
Which is that's an interesting layer over
everything that you've experienced.
So let me just kind of give you space and
let you decide where you would like
to begin about how in the world did you
get to be in that space and what
was that like? And we'll just weave back
and forth with all kinds of of questions.
Sounds great. So I am originally from the
East Coast and I landed
in Las Vegas because I went to grad school
out in LA.
And while I was out there, the LAPD was
not hiring,
but I wanted to work in what I thought was
crime scene investigations.
I, you know, before CSI came about,
so I'm gonna date myself, that wasn't even
a a a a ~ vision.
I went ~ to Cal State LA to go to their
criminalistic school and
it was fantastic because
Yeah, I was there during the O.J.
Simpson case. So talk about watching the
real world unfold.
~ you have our instructors were just they
were in the real world,
they were doing it. Christopher Darden
actually taught at our school.
He was one of the prosecutors on the case.
So just getting to see all that unfold in
front of me and seeing issues with crime
scene evidence, it just really sparked my
fire.
But as I got further along in my
education,
I realized I didn't want to be behind the
scenes.
I realized I wanted to be in the forefront
actually investigating
the crimes itself using that evidence.
And the Las Vegas Mudch Bond Police
Department came to our campus
and they did recruiting up there.
And my instructors said, lead instructors
said,
you know, in LA, you may not ever be able
to afford a house.
You might always have a two hour drive to
work.
~ we're not hiring, it's just all these
things.
Whereas Las Vegas at the time was this
huge growing city.
He said it's very proactive, ~
considerate.
So I went out to Las Vegas and just was
really impressed with the agency,
really proactive at the time. And there
was because it was a building city,
I knew that I could go many places in my
career.
So I went out there at 29 years old,
one of the oldest people in my academy.
I went and just what an amazing experience
to,
you know, go through the hard work of a of
an academy and then it
Gosh, it's fantastic agency. The training
was amazing.
And then went out into patrol and worked
in outlying areas such as Lawland,
Nevada. We have a substation out there.
I worked in criminal intelligence,
community policing. I also did sexual
assault crimes,
internal affairs, and then eventually
promoted.
When I was right before promoting,
they had an opportunity to ~ join the
crisis negotiation team.
So I went to the school.
went through the scenarios and got chosen
for the team.
And that was it was an amazing experience
to be able to respond to people
in crisis with a team and to work to help
them peacefully resolve it
so everyone was safe. And Las Vegas has
one of the busiest crisis negotiation
teams
in the United States. We were averaging
gosh,
you know, over a hundred call outs a year
just in because in Las Vegas,
some people come, it's their last stand.
It is
whether they running from a crime
themselves,
running from reality themselves,
or just find themselves on hard luck.
~ it was a very busy team. And so I got to
I was taught from some of
the best where two of my team members now
actually work for Black Swan,
Chief Dennis Flynn and Sergeant Don
Fieselman,
they were part of the negotiation team and
now part of Black Swan.
So was able to be a crisis negotiator,
~ promoted, went back into sexual assault.
was chosen to go to homicide and that was
a f so my dreams from being
a little kid of working on crime scenes
came to fruition as
a supervisor in homicide. And then went to
the police academy so
I could actually bring the help instruct
the new kids coming in.
And then my last ~ spot at the police
department was for I was the director
of the employee wellness and I was put
there after the events of one October
or the Mandalay Bay shooting.
which if you're not aware is the largest
mass ~ shooting in the United States.
And my job was to find resources for our
employees,
their families, as we healed from this
just devastating incident,
let alone the stressors of being involved
in law enforcement,
whether you're in corrections,
whether you were a civilian. There's cops
have problems just like everyone else.
So looking
Mm-hmm.
for ways to help people help themselves.
And so I retired in twenty-one and that
was an amazing place to go because
I learned so much about people and the
honor,
as I'm sure you know, of sitting with
people when they're in their darkest times
and helping them find resources.
That's wow, what a what an amazing story.
And I I have three questions. I'm just
gonna kind of toss them out and
you can take them at
Sure.
will, whichever in order you would like.
The first question I had as I was
listening to you describe your journey
was what was it about crime that appealed
to you
as a child that you were thinking,
that's the direction I'm going to go?
Right?
So that was that's one question.
Number two is when you experienced the
the education and the the the classes and
the the cohorts,
did you notice anything,
inner gender disparities? because I'm
imagining we might have some women
out there that are thinking, man,
that sounds really interesting,
but I'm kind of wondering
What's it gonna be like for a woman?
What's it gonna be like for me?
Am I gonna be treated equally?
What should I expect? All the things.
And then the third question I had is what
surprised
you the most about the negotiation
experience?
when you would engage with that,
when you engage with people and you're
trying to talk them down
and and prevent something horrible from
happening,
what was something that you experienced
along the way that was surprising?
To you that you didn't see coming.
Sure. Those are great questions.
And you know, my memory will go like this,
so you'll have to get me back on track,
I'm sure. ~
Ha ha ha. ~
you you know, you ask why in law
enforcement,
I am the first law enforcement person in
my family.
So so there is no history, there is no
mentorship,
nothing. ~ I think as a young girl,
I was an avid reader. I was a Nancy Drew
girl.
So reading those stories, loving the
trying to solve puzzles,
trying to figure things out. And then as a
young girl,
the show Quincy.
Where he for those that aren't our you
know,
of our age, he was a medical examiner who
got to solve crimes.
Which is Hollywood. It's not even real,
but it just sucked me in. I was allowed to
watch one show on TV a week
and I wanted to watch Quincy. So that
really Right,
I remember like Columbo.
right.
So I just wanted to have an alligator on
my boat like you know,
Quincy did. But it just that kind of
sucked me in,
just like the Hollywood idea of what it
was to solve crime kind of
got me interested at first. I'm like,
that's really interesting. And then as I
got further into it,
realizing that it was really great to put
pieces together.
It was I love the way that you could use
your brain and everyone's brain
to kind of solve problems, solve
situations,
and then just help people in a difficult
situation.
I'm a helper by nature. So I just it
really appealed to so many of you know
my gifts I feel and my drives.
So that's what really got
me into it, but my father said,
because he the last thing he wanted was a
daughter that was a cop because
he was scared for me. And he goes,
Yeah.
please don't do that here. Do it somewhere
where we're not worried every day.
Because we see a news and you might not
even be working,
but we've assumed that you've done it.
And he's like, and please get your
education first just in case you don't
like it.
You have something to fall back on.
So just do a
Nice.
dual path. And so absolutely and I agreed.
And and so that's why I went west coast ~
to be a police officer.
~ you'd asked about
Nice. So the gender or
gender and that you it's such a great
question.
~ I am the youngest of three girls and and
I kind of call myself the
boy of the family because my dad was like,
What's happening? Right, you know,
I need someone to play sports.
Ha ha
So
I we we were always very active.
And this is gonna sound strange as I never
had considered my gender would ever
be an issue of not getting what I want,
because that was never an issue in our
house,
right? Is you know, you want to work hard,
you wanna put the work in, you're gonna
achieve what you want.
It's about putting the work in and
treating people well.
You'll you'll get there. But when I went
to the police department,
you realize that there were some very
gifted women that paved the way
for me that worked hard, that they,
you know, became police officers when it
was so rare.
That I knew coming in, I had some mentors
I could work with and I sought them out.
And one of the best pieces of advice that
I was given early on is work
so well with others.
Work so hard with others that your gender
is not an issue.
Just do the work. Don't make it about
you're this or you're that.
You're just a great worker. You're a great
teammate.
You are someone people can rely on.
And I think by focusing on the work at
hand,
focusing on teamwork, focusing on the
goal,
made it that people wanted me on their
team.
And it wasn't until I went to homicide
where they made a really big deal that
I was the first female homicide sergeant.
And they wanted to do a media piece on it
and I balked.
And I said, I'm not comfortable with this
because I worked really hard
to be the best candidate. I don't
Mm.
want someone to think I got this because I
was a girl.
And the public information officer pulled
me aside and said,
Look, that's great that you've worked
really hard.
But there are people out there that don't
know as a woman or as anything that they
can do it despite or because of.
So just if you could do this piece for us,
talk.
Explain how you got there because you're
gonna give hope to someone that doesn't
real that didn't have that background
where of course you can do everything.
And and I did it. And it's funny because
cops are interesting people.
I was given a hard time about it by,
you know, my fellow male officers,
Yeah, I'm sure you are. Yeah.
like, you know, you know, but you take
that in good fun because
the more important piece was could this
help someone else to realize that yes,
you can do it? ~ and so that's o the only
place I ever saw that really gender came
up. Like I said, Vegas was a very
proactive agency with some amazing role
models ahead of me that had paved
the way by doing the work. And so I wasn't
coming in as a detriment.
I was coming in as an asset.
I love that. I love that. And I have
another question along those same lines
and I'm gonna try to word it the right
way.
It's kind of in my head and I I hope I'm
gonna get out of my mouth
in the correct way. But have you ever run
into a scenario because people have
different points of view of things,
and sometimes we make assumptions about
other people's actions or lack of action.
And I talk to people sometimes about
prejud prejudicial kind of experiences and
that type of thing.
Did you ever run into a situation where
someone was kind of projecting
and and and determining that they were
being treated some kind of
way because of some kind of profiling
going on when that actually wasn't the
case.
When it was like 'cause you were you did
the opposite.
You the way I heard you just said we you
were going into it like just be
a good team player. I don't really want to
see myself as different.
Just be be there, show up.
connect, do the good job. D did you ever
run into situations where
for whatever reason someone seemed to have
a chip on their shoulder
and they were assuming that other people
were treating them differently because
of something about them when that actually
wasn't the case?
All the time. I mean, I think that it's
people can you know everyone
has their own perspective, their own
reason for why things are happening.
And I think you can often fall back on
that versus getting curious about
why is this happening? So I I think I had
to learn early on.
I I was glad I had some life experience
before I became a
cop because that's important, right?
You you put these young eighteen to
twenty-one year old kids out there,
and I call them kids, they're young adults
out there.
To solve help people solve problems when
they have no experience
in that area whatsoever. And it's kind of
like,
how are you gonna help? Where I learned
early is that,
hey, not everybody is like you,
not everyone has the same background or
thinking and and let them lead you
as to how they got there. So removing
assumptions was really key to me,
is that I've just got to be curious about
how we got there,
why we're here, and don't assume you know
where they're going.
Let them show you or tell you.
and then help guide them because they've
been able to express where they are.
I think that really helped me because
everyone has their perspective.
They're they're coming into the situation
with their chip or their experiences.
Well it was my job to figure out what that
was so at least I could understand what
the issue was or help point back to,
well, maybe there's another reason why the
cops are here today or people here today
or what you weren't pulled over because of
ABC.
It was because of this. And when you can
explain to someone,
you know,
How are you seeing it and listen to it?
Then that often allowed me the opportunity
to kind of explain what
was really going on because I gave them
the space ~ to express themselves.
That's awesome. And I can totally see how
that would play into
the negotiation experience of what I'm
hearing you describe
is is listening, creating, asking,
having a curiosity, creating the space,
giving them that area to express and and
describe what it is that they're feeling
and why, and and giving that some honor,
giving that some respect. And then trying
to work from there.
Is that
And and and that that I mean, that seems
like that's really a lot
of what an effective negotiator would be
able to do.
And then also to the last question,
and I'm kind of jumping around a little
bit,
but something that surprised you that when
you went engaged in these scenarios with
people that were experiencing a lot of
different things,
maybe it had a lot of interesting and
possibly traumatic backgrounds that
Yeah.
They were assuming some things about
themselves and about other people because
of some horrible things they have
experienced in their life.
and you go in into a negotiating ~
platform,
what is one thing that surprised you,
whether it was about yourself or whether
it was about the situation
or other people that you didn't expect,
you didn't see coming?
Well, I can tell you going in as a crisis
negotiator and you know,
your first case, my first case I had was a
gentleman who had robbed a bank.
And I'm gonna tell you I've never robbed a
bank.
I've never committed a felony crime in my
life like that.
So going in, there's a lot of pressure on
you.
It's like, how am I ever going to engage
with this person,
let alone everyone's listening to you?
And I what really surprised me is it
doesn't matter who the person is.
There is a universal need for every person
to be heard.
To be seen and to be understood.
Love this. Love it.
I mean,
here it's a universal. And so it there's a
reason why negotiators were brought into
existence. If we only had SWAT,
the big cars and all this coming up,
and I walked up the door and I just
started yelling,
Hey, come on, you idiot, you know,
what have you done? Get your butt out
here.
They're coming in. Realize we've created a
dynamic for violence.
I mean, just that is not gonna end.
Something bad is gonna happen.
Maybe someone's gonna come up because they
respect the the the force authority.
But in the end, that's not going to end
well.
The reason why negotiators are there is to
kind of let's bring the temperature down.
And when you can allow the someone the
ability to start to think,
to express themselves, and I know I'm
preaching to the choir with you.
When you can let them bring those
emotions,
they start to go down. When those emotions
go down when they're expressed,
then all of a sudden that rational
thinking is going up.
And now we've got something to work with.
Right. So that's was truly surprising.
Where it was it was so scary to pick up
the phone or s get them engaged
to start with. But in the end,
you knew what was gonna work is if you
just allow the person without judgment,
because I can if I judge you all day for
what you're doing,
you're not gonna, you're not gonna
interact with me.
We're not gonna get anywhere. It's non
judgmental.
I don't know how you got here.
But if I can get you to express how and
kind of explain what's going on.
All of a sudden, you that are in crisis
are gonna be able to,
you're gonna start to think clearer.
All of a sudden clarity is gonna come in,
logic's gonna come in. Okay, wait,
we I need to figure this out. How we're
gonna solve this.
Because in the end, I'm selling the person
in crisis mostly jail time.
That's what's gonna happen today,
right? What I don't want is for this
crisis to get worse,
you to hurt yourself, you to hurt anyone
else.
We're trying to figure out a way to
resolve this so we can you can move
forward from
here.
And so I was really surprised at how even
though I would think we would
be so different because I've never robbed
a bank,
I've never murdered someone, just giving
that person the opportunity to kind
of work through this, they're in a spot
and we need to figure out how
to help them walk out of it, but they're
not walking alone because my job
is to all of a sudden walk across the
field in mentally and kind of
see the world through your eyes.
and kind of have kind of engage with you
so we are both seeing it
and trying to resolving it, collaborating
together to help you be safe.
It doesn't mean there's not going to be
consequences.
I true.
It doesn't
mean it's not changing all that.
Instead it's giving them that opportunity
to,
okay, how do we how do we move forward
from here?
That is that is awesome. And I'm really
kind of wanting your thoughts
on do you feel like that the action,
the crime, is almost a secondary a
secondary issue?
~ let me give you an example. When I talk
to people that ~
are expressing where they have they're
abusing ~ or using excessively maybe
alcohol
or or some kind of medication.
And people focus on that so much,
but when you're talking to them,
you find out that's just a secondary
thing.
That's not the original thing.
That that's that's just a response to the
original thing.
So I'm
Absolutely.
as you're talking, that's coming in my
mind and I'm wondering
what
your thoughts are on the crime being the
secondary thing
to what the original issue actually is.
And it usually is whether it's,
I mean, if you think about it,
if if someone doesn't need money,
then they're not going to go to work.
They're not going to rob a bank.
They're not going to do all the things to
get money,
right? So there's a need there that is not
being fulfilled.
Whether they've done other things,
there's a need that they have that there's
a basic need that they're trying to get,
and they're doing it in a different way
than say I would or you would do.
There's something going on there.
So what's what's led us to this point?
And when you get and get someone to kind
of talk about why they're in the
situation,
how they're getting there, once again it's
allowing someone
the opportunity to explain their situation
and and it provides me an area
to kind of help them. Okay, so where are
we gonna where are we gonna go today?
Where can we go to how can I help you get
through this?
So I think there's always gonna be
secondary issues.
I mean, you know, if there's a crime that
happens of violence,
something's happened beforehand for the
most part that has
there's some kind of trigger that
something that's happened.
Not placing blame anywhere than where it
needs to be,
but there's something
Mm-hmm.
else underlying that has occurred.
And and that's, you know, usually a
trigger response of why we're there that
day.
That's fabulous because what I'm hearing
you say are two things.
One, there's a secondary issue,
right? And also, there are natural,
what I call natural consequences of our
behavioral choices.
Those those both of those need to be,
yes, we can understand that the actual
crime is a secondary thing.
There's there's a core issue that happened
before that.
Like you said, maybe a need that has not
been met and they have poor coping skills.
They don't know how to get this need met.
You don't know what the what background
they came out of.
And also, since they're an adult and they
chose to behave in this way,
because there's other people out there
that maybe have experienced something
similar
that they experienced growing up,
some kind of trauma or or you know,
some negative experience that did not
respond with crime.
Right. So and there does need to be
natural because I feel like if somebody
goes
Too far in either direction. If they're if
they're too much,
bless their heart. It's just all they were
traumatized.
They shouldn't be held accountable because
they had a bad upbringing.
If they go too far in that direction,
then that's not going to end well.
But neither does it end well, it seems
like,
if somebody's way too punitive and they
have no interest in finding
out what what caused the person to do that
to begin with.
Seems like there needs to be a balance,
and that's what I'm hearing you say.
Correct. In in in in my opinion is
absolutely.
I mean, we are we are not ro we're not
robots.
We are all our own individual
circumstances,
but each of us is responsible for our own
actions,
our own choices, even given, like you
said,
you could have two people that have the
same exact upbringing,
you know, same against issues,
it could be horrific, but they don't make
the same choices.
That's on them, right? And it just is so
yeah,
accountability is always important,
but there's also, you know
I think it's important is how how does
someone heal?
How does someone move forward?
And it might not help the person that they
have harmed,
but in the end, there's still a human that
we're trying to to in
the long term salvage for their own their
own life.
It just is you my hope is that for
everyone can heal in their own way.
Yeah, that's fabulous. Now I want to take
this next section segment here,
and I'm very fascinated in how you are
using your experience with crisis
negotiation and a lot of the things that
we've been talking about so
far into the corporate space,
into the business space, and helping these
leaders use these skills that
you have developed in in a corporate
space.
So help us kind of connect those dots.
Absolutely. So Chris Voss is a genius.
~ so Chris Voss, for those that don't
know,
he was in the FBI crisis negotiator.
Amazing crisis negotiation saves
throughout the world.
And as he left, he's Harvard trained.
He kind of went to Harvard and was able to
kind of turn some other negotiation
personnels on end by thinking a little
differently.
And he has written a book called Never
Split the Difference.
So it's 10 years old this month,
and it's a great.
book that takes crisis negotiation
principles.
What I learned going through the FBI
negotiation school,
what Chris learned being a crisis
negotiator with the FBI,
taking what we've learned and and he's
enhanced them,
but taking them to the business world,
how this can truly translate. And he has
adopted something called tactical empathy,
which is actually being able to recognize
the perspective of another person
and then verbally ~ verbalizing that what
you're seeing perspective.
demonstrating through that verbalizing
that you're seeking
to understand their perspective.
And it is incredible how in the
negotiation world it is making
it about the other party first before it's
about yourself.
We're so often in the business world
negotiation,
it's me, me, me, my ask, what can I get?
Instead, it's making about the other
person first to truly understand where
they're
coming from. And by that, you're able then
to collaborate knowing their vision.
Because vision is going to drive decision.
So he's written this book. There are now
he teaches,
we teach, you know, people all over the
world.
We most of the instructor our instructors
are crisis negotiators
or experienced business people.
And it is fascinating that teaching these
simple skills,
they're all communication skills,
they're active listening skills,
with the core being listening first,
making it about the other person,
that you're able to make deals you never
even thought were.
possible because you've got two sides
working together.
And it has been fascinating that it's a
joy to be able to help others
who are I mean, they've bigger brains than
I'll ever have,
have done seen
Well.
things I've never seen and are talking
about dollars that I will never even
understand. But being able to help them
create things they never thought were
possible by some simple, you know,
skills, whether it's one-on-one coaching
or coming to events.
it's really been fascinating. And it's
great to work with a bunch
of other crisis negotiators and business
leaders who really seek to help others.
I think these kind of skills should be
taught middle school and high school
because
you're teaching people
I agree.
how to listen first because and listening
for the reason behind
why people are saying what they're saying
instead of listening just long enough
so that I can respond. It's just a
different way of doing business.
And I love it. It's just been fascinating.
~ ma
it sounds amazing. So I have two
questions.
I'll see if I can get them both out before
one of them disappears.
If we're bringing brutally honest hair.
You're so like me. I love it. I love it.
So one of them is
What do you feel is the biggest obstacle
to listening?
Like why is it that why do people have
because it sounds like,
well, that's a no-brainer. Then why do we
have such a frickin' problem with it?
So that's question one. And question two
is,
what is the main issue that
you have heard business leaders come to
you all with?
What is their main what do you hear over
and over and over again that is
the that is a struggle that business
leaders have to deal with that
you you're trying to come in and and
support them with?
So those those two different questions.
Okay, so first of all, listening.
Listening is hard. Listening, we are
programmed,
I think, to listen to respond.
You know, there's we c there's five levels
of listening with Black Swan.
The lowest is just listening and you're
like you're doing other things,
just the gist. You can pop in and out.
I call it the mother in law, where you
just go,
uh-huh, uh-huh. Just let the conversation
go.
Ha ha ha ha. ~
Or
or then the next is listening to problem
solve.
And I think as a cop, that's a lot of what
I did is I'm listening long enough like
I got a solution. I got it.
But what that does is if you're only
listening to that,
you're not allowing your counterpart to
truly explain where they're coming from,
what they're talking about. You're almost
you're dismissing where they're at.
Instead, we focus on listening for the
reason behind what they're saying
and for the emotions that are tied to it.
And I think we are so programmed in the
business world with scripts,
I gotta get through A, B, and C and D,
or I gotta do my ask first, so I get my
stuff out there.
is we miss an opportunity to just listen
and just allow the other person to,
as we all know, get that rational thinking
up,
stress down, get the emotions down.
So we're actually logically thinking and
working together.
~ I just think we're just programmed to go
play ping bong when we talk versus taking
the time to soak in what someone's saying
and then get more curious about what
they've just said. So I I just think we're
just not taught to do that.
Right. I got that. Makes a lot of sense.
And plus a lot of those like listening to
solve a problem,
it appears helpful, but really it's it's
it's so the person can feel better about
solving the problem.
Right. And and often I find that so have
teenage kids and I I listen
to problem solve all the time because
that's my go-to sometimes with them,
right? I mean, that's my job. But if I
instead listen to what they're saying
and kind of get curious about it,
all of a sudden as they're talking,
they're solving the problem themselves.
Now all of a sudden if I tell how to do
something,
they're not gonna do it. Or it could be
reluctant or whatever.
But if they it's their idea, guess what?
All of a sudden they're doing it because
it's their idea.
And that's where I think we miss by
allowing someone else to solve their
problem.
You can be there with them, but allow them
to solve it themselves makes
it there's ownership over it. And people
more tend to do it than if you're trying
to just problem solve. I because I don't
think everyone wants their problem solved
for them. Some people just want to vent.
Some people just
Mm-hmm.
want to express what they're feeling.
And if you problem solve, you're not
giving them that opportunity
to actually get out that expression.
Yeah, absolutely. So the the next question
was about,
and we'll do this and then we're gonna get
to how the listeners and
the viewers can get more of you.
So the next question was, what was the
what's the main struggle that
the business leaders have? What what are
what are the what do you hear?
What what comes on repeat from these these
fabulous men and women leaders
who are struggling and trying to do a good
job and they're reaching out going,
my gosh.
Please help me with this. I've tried
everything I know to try.
I I I can't get it fixed. It keeps
happening over and over.
What would that be?
Think often is we have our go-to ways of
fixing things.
So we can sit and we can discuss,
hey, you know what? We're going to make
sure we make it about
the other person first. We're going to
change,
you know, kind of our how we're our
sequencing.
We're going to first make it about the
other person.
We're going to get all that information
out.
And then we're going to see things from
the same side.
Like, that's great. And then they work
against themselves and go right back
to what they are used to doing.
I think so often we're.
People are scared to try it or they're
like,
nope, that's never gonna we work against
ourselves.
I see that so often. And I think too,
is with black swan skills, I mean,
we have different things called like
labels,
whereas different things that we do.
If you don't actually practice them,
if you don't put them out in the low
stakes,
like with your friends, your family,
you know, going to a restaurant,
practicing these skills, when the big
negotiation comes,
you don't have the confidence that it's
gonna work.
So you just put it aside.
So it's kind of like if I read a book
about working out,
I read it every week, but I never lift a
weight.
I can't expect
Yeah.
to see anything different. So I think it's
kind of shifting the mindset
of this does take work, it's, you know,
and it takes consistency, but you're gonna
see great results.
And we hear it all the time, people that I
tried it,
I did it, this, and we get excited emails
or excited,
you know, calls back. It's like it worked.
I can't believe it worked, but I practiced
like you said,
and then put it into practice and it was
perfect.
And and that's what we love to hear is
people trusting that
I love that. And y you're absolutely
right.
You're absolutely right. ~ I I teach the
same thing to my to my patients.
You know, if they're like, for example,
deep breathing, I said, we could go
through ~ an exercise in the office
and you can have a great experience,
but you need to practice it just when
you're calm.
And I say practice
Right.
it several times throughout the day.
I tell exactly how to do it, so that when
that moment comes when you feel like
you might be having to battle a panic
attack.
you've got the skills and your body just
knows how to do it.
You don't have to think about it because
you've done it so much,
it's just on autopilot. But it takes that
practice to be able to do it.
Like you said in the low stakes platforms.
Mm-hmm. Right. Absolutely.
Awesome. Well
Annette, so how it how can my listeners
and viewers find you?
If they want to get in contact with
Mm-hmm.
you, they they want more of what you've
got,
where do they go?
So Black Swan Group is a website that you
can go to.
You can find me on LinkedIn. You can find
Chris Voss and the Black Swan Group
all over YouTube. There's a new book that
has just been released,
and I'll show it to you, that takes the
the ~ the the never split
the difference and brings it into another.
It's called Fight Less, Win More.
And it's like it's taking what are great
hostage negotiation skills
and really putting it in personal and
business.
a lot of how we've adapted the skills from
ten years ago.
So it's a great it's I actually gave it to
my sisters and they're like,
how never to get in a fight with my
husband book?
I'm like, yes, yes. It's about it's about
Ha ha ha.
learning about each other again,
even though you've been together for
years.
But I highly recommend that. But yeah,
on LinkedIn, ~ just please find me.
And ~ I guess I'm very grateful for the
opportunity Black Swan has given
and I think it really can help
Fabulous. Annette, this has been great.
I I so appreciate you and you being
willing to spend your precious time
and your effort and also being vulnerable
and sharing some
of your personal experiences and and and
the the wisdom that you've gleaned
throughout the years from your from your
time with crisis negotiation
to share it with with me, with my
listeners,
with my viewers. Thank you, Annette,
so so much.
Well, thank you. And it's been a joy to
listen to your podcast.
I love what you're doing for people to see
that there's so many places
you can go even when you're down in the
dust.
So I'm really grateful for what you're
doing for others.
So thank you.
Thank you, Annette. Now, hey, listeners,
viewers, listen, I know that you've heard
at least five things today that you're
thinking, I know one of my friends,
I know a coworker, I have a family member
that needs to hear exactly what Annette
just said. So take this podcast episode,
copy and paste it, send it into that in a
text,
send it an email, put it on your favorite
social media platform so we can grow.
our Phoenix and Flame community to let
people know you are not alone.
I hope your day has been great.
I hope the rest of your day is fantastic.
I'm Dana on Phoenix and Flame.